a lovely bank holiday monday by the
river in bewdley in worcestershire
no restrictions on travelling to enjoy
the view
but here social distancing appears to be
holding up
even if some feel their commitment has
been sorely tested by the example set by
the prime minister's special adviser
they expect us people to do what we're
doing
in a civil way and yet that man can get
in his car
travel 500 mile round trip
and and face no consequences
others are more sympathetic towards mr
cummings
candidly admitting he's not the only
person likely to have viewed the
guidelines
according to his own circumstances other
people have done a lot worse
but he's been being loyal for his thing
is i mean
life's got to carry on and he did it for
his son didn't he really
i don't see is there anything wrong yes
he's travelled all their miles
but he did it for his son's safety it's
impossible to know whether people
gathering by the seaside or in parks
less than two meters apart
all live under the same roof but
behavioral scientists say the lockdown
is now more easily open to
interpretation
once you begin blurring the boundaries
around the rules
and being ambiguous about them and
finding all sorts of hidden clauses that
actually would develop for other
purposes
then you're really opening the gates for
people to say
well i have exceptional circumstances or
i can interpret it in this way
one household which has stuck rigidly to
the rules is the house of god
worcester cathedral has been closed to
worshippers since the start of the
crisis
not even open for funerals the bishop of
worcester has consoled those for whom
the restrictions
have governed the way they can grieve he
worries about the impact now on
society's faith
in the lockdown i think a huge amount of
damage
has been done in this situation by
people not
perceiving those in authority to be
living by the same rule book which they
themselves are articulating and it's
going to take a huge amount
for that trust to be recovered but it's
essential for the health and safety
of us all that it is recovered somehow
because it's a matter of life and death
predicting the amount of damage dominic
cummings's actions
could have if a second lockdown is
needed is not an exact science
the hope is whatever his reasoning the
rest of us will understand
our interactions are being curtailed to
prevent the spread
of a killer virus lisa holland sky news
worcestershire